so my wise to inspire people to do the
things that inspire them so to eat so
together each of us can change our world
for the better and so the things that
inspire me I'm a sucker for stories of
service when I hear anybody sacrifice
for somebody else it could be a child
like I well up every time I'm a total
softy for stories of sacrifice and
giving right and probably another reason
I by the way equally drawn to artists as
I am to the military I think they're the
same people
they're both compelled they both the
drug they both went into it knowing that
they wouldn't get rich you know I met
somebody in the military said he's on
his this is his get rich slow plan there
is an intense camaraderie with others in
their field and they do it strictly so
that others may benefit almost entirely
right I'm very drawn to artists and and
and and servicemen and service women
alike but I think one of the things that
I've seen I met in all veterans whether
they love the military or not a hundred
percent of them missed the camaraderie
they miss the Brotherhood in the
sisterhood they miss the fact that they
know that even if they hate someone that
person will risk their life to save
theirs that's pretty intense you know
that they know that they're stronger
because of the group they recognize that
they're weak by themselves but they're
part of a machine that makes them strong
and it's the opportunity to give of
themselves that is the most fulfilling
thing in the world and then when we when
they separate and they go into the into
the private sector it doesn't matter how
smart they are as a matter how much
they've accomplished and that's a
different story by the way I think the
military could do a better job and how
we set people up when they enter private
sector because we don't teach them about
the transferable skill sets I meet
people who who've been in the service
for 15 20 years and they think they have
nothing to offer a private sector
because they've been it and you know
they've done some obscure job that's
only relevant to the military and yet
they've learned about leeched leadership
they've learned about how to operate
under pressure they've learned about
teamwork I mean they know more about
business than most business people but
we don't tell them the transferable
skill set we look at the superficial
stuff that's a different story
but I think that the thing that people
miss is the camaraderie and then we drop
them into the business world which is
predominantly selfish and lonely and
dog-eat-dog right and just like vets who
are struggling with PTSD the ones that
really get themselves healthy again are
the ones that find support groups of
people who can relate to them and I
think businesses are the same I mean if
you're a business owners one of the
reasons you came to a place like this
because by the way there's nothing
that's being said on the stage that you
can't find for free online right the
reason you came here is for each other
to meet each other to get to know each
other to meet people who understand your
stresses and strains because it's
freaking lonely right make friends while
you hear something you can call him just
vent and be like I'm struggling today I
hate it I don't want to keep doing this
and they'll be like yeah I know how you
feel just that just to know that
somebody out there understands gives you
the energy to keep going so I think one
of the most important things for for
military who are adjusting is you don't
need to have PTSD you don't need to have
something you know a diagnosis as you
separate and go into private sector I
think we need those kinds of support
groups of people who know are going
through know what it's like and let's do
this together
you know and who knows maybe they'll
even start businesses together which
would be even better
[Music]